one of the first things i learned about
batman uh
in talking to the dc dc guys when we uh
went to talk to them before batman
begins is
the character of batman thrives on
reinterpretation
uh and each generation kind of creates
its own own version and that's that's
what keeps the
the legend so sort of uh fresh in a way
and uh having worked with rob i could
say with total confidence that
he can do absolutely anything he sets
his mind to and i could not be more
excited to see what he does with batman
the dark knight trilogy director
christopher nolan is definitely
on board with robert pattinson as our
next batman
the hell are you supposed to be
i'm vengeance the trailer for matt
reeves interpretation dropped during the
dc
fandom event in august with a planned
release for october 2021
you're part of this too
oh my part of it
you'll see
[Music]
but et has confirmed filming on the
batman has come to a halt
just three days after resuming
production after a member of the
production tested positive for covet 19.
vanity fair reported on thursday that
the person that tested positive
is in fact robert pattinson
[Music]
well i've seen too much well we'll try
and keep up pattinson is also starring
opposite john david washington in
nolan's time-bending
tenet you want to crash a plane we're
not from the air no it's so dramatic
well how big a plane
that part is a little dramatic the movie
crashes into select theaters around the
u.s
labor day weekend a decision that has
become divisive among audiences
amid the global pandemic anytime people
are
uh really keen to to see something
you've done that's obviously thrilling
as a filmmaker but
obviously we're hopeful that people will
be patient with the role of the film
and wait for it to to come to their area
um
the studio i think is doing a remarkable
job of slowly and safely rolling out the
film across the world
as theaters uh are able to open um
and you know hopefully people can be
patient with the with the release of the
film
um the theaters are
they've committed to the studio to play
it for a long period of time and
and so we'll we'll be there for a while
for people to discover in their own time
you